[Music]
hello I'm Dustin Kirkland a product
manager at Google and your host at coop
con Copenhagen I'm joined here by one of
my colleagues Matt Rickard who's its
software engineer on Google's container
tools team Matt tell us a little bit
about scaffold sure scaffold is a
developer workflow tool made kind of
specifically for kubernetes it helps you
get started with kubernetes it helps you
develop your apps on kubernetes and it
really targets that kind of inter
development workflow of building deploy
and it also kind of utilizes some of the
other tools that that we published on
our team such as canna Co which is our
on cluster build system so the idea is
that you can use scaffold to not only
build in deploy but with your cluster as
your only kind of dependency and
scaffold interfaces with other other
aspects of google kubernetes or
kubernetes in general yes so the the
kubernetes api is kind of like exactly
what we're targeting so with scaffold
it's it's pluggable in the sense that
you can build and deploy in a variety of
ways but your cluster is really the only
thing that you need so a developer
writing some code on their on their on
their MacBook walk us through
I just wrote some Ruby and I want to
deploy that to gke sure so you write
your code you write your docker file
which is kind of your way to describe
your container image you write some
kubernetes manifests which is how you're
going to describe your your resources on
your kubernetes cluster and then you
write the scaffold DMO file which
actually just brings both of those
together and gives you the full kind of
metadata from source to deployment so
scaffold takes that scaffold gamal it'll
build your image it'll deploy it it'll
actually introspect your your image for
all of your source code dependencies and
perform a file watch on that so when
those files change it kicks off that
rapid development loop and you're able
to kind of get that native experience
but on a cluster and then you're cooking
with grease all right I understand you
have a demo for us you want to walk us
through this demo sure so here I have
I'm just in the getting started portion
of the the scaffold repository you can
check this out
Google container tools slash scaffold
and what I have here is I have a very
basic go program here it's just gonna
print hello world every second I have a
docker file that describes it so here
I'm using a multi-stage docker file you
could really use any sort of docker file
here that you want and then I have a
very simple kubernetes resource
definition here which is just a pod that
deploys this getting started container
on my cluster if we look a little bit at
the the scaffold VM well you can see
kind of two main parts to it the first
being build and we just have a list of
artifacts here the first being our
scaffold example the really cool thing
about scaffold is that you can deploy
multiple images and multiple deployments
at the same time so the idea behind that
is that in this kind of micro service
world cloud native world your services
you know might be split up into many
different micro services and you'll need
to be developing on multiple of those at
the same time I'm so scared of supports
all sorts of workflows like that and
then the deploy stands that here is
basically just saying take all my
kubernetes manifest and deploy them and
I'll just go ahead and I'll do a
scaffold dev so this is just gonna do a
build and deploy and then perform kind
of a watch on the filesystem
dependencies so you can see that we're
we're streaming our logs from our kind
of deployed artifacts here it's just
saying hello world every second now that
deployed locally or that deploy to the
cloud yeah so good question so here I'm
using a mini cube cluster so it's local
to my laptop but scaffold works both
remotely and on local clusters and there
are some optimizations that we make for
the local cases where we don't have to
kind of push all the artifacts around
but the experience is exactly the same
so so now I'm just going to go and
change some code here I'm gonna say
hello coop con and then I just saved it
and this will read this will kick off
the kind of build and deploy cycle again
and you can see that we've already
redeployed our new pod and it's printing
out hello coop cons so you get that
really kind of fast inner development
loop of
for for your work that was incredibly
incredibly fast it's so of course you
know this is a minimal example so we're
only deploying a very small go binary
but in practice it is it is quite fast
and have you heard from users using
scaffold for much larger maybe real
production type workloads yeah
absolutely and in that case you know
it's still great for that kind of inner
development loop but we also have a mode
called scaffold run and so scaffold run
will just run this build and deploy
pipeline one so the idea is that you can
you can call this from you know a
product such as Google container builder
or you know Jenkins or spinnaker and
then you can kind of have the same kind
of see ICD workflow as you have locally
so that kind of bridges the gap and
users aren't left on this cliff of
having all of these tools locally and
then having to relearn something else in
their see ICD pipelines that's superb